[Music]
so you guys uh see patty the baddie win
at ufc yeah and he he had a powerful
message at the end that we were going to
talk
about want to dedicate this fight to
little baby lee
i love your accent
sounds like hannah
that's for you
damn
right before the weigh-in that's rough
dude he still won that fight that's
crazy man
please speak to someone that's cool
great actor wow great
i don't know i don't know what he said
but it's accidental
and at some point i i swear to god he
was gonna be like try to catch me lucky
charms i thought
he's good so that's not conor mcgregor i
followed the rainbow i thought he was
going to say that but like he did it
that's good way to mask boys way to mask
no no um
the best part about that though is him
like right after he's he gave that
interview he just started crying like he
like fell to his knees started crying so
yeah like he was like sobbing yeah i was
watching the fight he's one of his best
friends passed away yeah and like you
just see him like he's he's walking back
to the the back room and he just like
sobbing the whole time like you just see
it like it looks like he all that
emotion was like weighing really heavy
on him so like after that fight cultural
context wise right so like us you know
we're we're we're um we're west coast
fairy boys right we're like more like a
little bit more in tune with emotions
especially in entertainment and people
talk and whatever it's more of an
accepted place to do that i would say 10
years ago if i showed any signs
of like weaknesses or whatever people
immediately call me gay
they would just immediately just be like
your bestest friends would just laugh at
you and they're like what's wrong with
you dude like they'll actually
make fun of you for opening up about any
any struggle and some sometimes it's
serious struggle sometimes it's you're
sad because your parents left or
whatever and then it's just a shitty
environment because especially how me
and bart grew up
um you're around like
violent macho dudes who also are masking
what they went through and then and the
way they hit their pain was just beating
up other dudes or whatever and it's like
they don't want to be reminded of their
pain so if you open up then it makes
them hurt so everyone protected
themselves by just like being aggressive
against reminding themselves of how much
their life sucks
now right like you feel like the world
has changed because l.a changed and you
feel like though just because this
bubble this west coast bubble and maybe
your friend circle change you feel like
so did everybody else but in reality
blue-collar communities all over the
world are still like this and then i
think also um we do have this idea that
white people don't struggle right so
like a lot of minority communities think
white guys got it good but apparently
what hannah tells told me is that in her
so so he's from um
that side of england scouser yeah
they're they're they're they're you know
like liverpool whatever they don't get
knocked out they don't get
yeah so like in ireland
the stigma uh in wales and like
they're they're like some hard ass dudes
hard
coal mining old school great depression
white dude mentality right like like no
one talks about how they feel they're
out fist fighting all day and it's a
stereotype but it's also like i would
say 1995 l.a so then
in that community they don't talk about
how they feel so then um she has family
friends that it's like this thing that's
going on right now where like dudes just
can't deal with their [ __ ] and then they
off themselves really and you're talking
about tough-ass guys like you're talking
about veterans that came back you're
talking about guys that like you know
they're like they were the talk of the
town because they're great at fist
fighting or whatever and then they all
just one day break down and and and and
then they get their families get a phone
call like oh yeah this guy you know he
offed himself and then so she's like
yeah it's like a thing that's happening
it's probably happening all over the
world but like it's a it's a problem in
paddy's area too yeah so that's why and
it's crazy that a guy like him who is
seen as a very masculine guy
he's a fighter he just won one of the
biggest fights in his career for him to
have that message off the jump and for
him to deliver it
with like
he delivered that message very well
because you see so many fighters that
have post fight interviews and they're
just trying to like talk about anything
coming out with a new nft yeah yeah like
they're just like [ __ ] fumbling at
all i'm going to disneyland and this guy
[ __ ] nailed it and it's i think it
means a lot to that community if a guy
like patty the baddie is speaking out
about these issues you know so he's the
man dude that's why everyone loves them
that's why barstool is paying him a got
a lot of money yup because if if they
think that that's like a sign of
weakness right and if a guy still do
yeah oh yeah
yeah but 100 they think that it's a sign
of weakness in a man that they think is
already weak comes out and says like if
i say it you need to talk about it
you're gonna say you get knocked out all
the time you [ __ ] idiot but then
patty batty says it oh [ __ ] it's
different when someone that they respect
says it then it's like oh [ __ ] maybe i
should [ __ ] maybe it's all right then
cause then the toughest [ __ ] who
beats up dudes who i feel is like
a tough macho dude then is like all
right [ __ ] well if he's okay with it
maybe it's okay to open up about it that
would be tight if if like on better help
they had an extension if you're a tough
guy you call this dude and he's like the
[ __ ] is up man how you feeling and he's
talking to you like you're a tough guy i
don't know man not too great
that's how they all maintain that
language so you don't feel like [ __ ]
yeah that's right or it's just mike
tyson yeah so you get that soft voice
but you also know he's a monster that
guy that guy is always ready to cry
because he went through some [ __ ] like
he you can tell he's like ready to yeah
at all times yeah hello
what's wrong
what's been bothering you watching my
grandpa growing up like
being taught not to cry and [ __ ] i'm
like man there's nobody who needs to cry
more than this man you know what i mean
like nobody who like went to war and all
kinds of [ __ ] and like he didn't want to
talk about anything he wanted to just
sink into movies every night and [ __ ]
drink himself to sleep and like yeah
like i wish that guy would have opened
up because like he didn't want to
jesus like that's [ __ ] [ __ ] i've never
seen my father cry
come to think of it not once not once
what about either sister's first uh baby
not even then
wow
yeah i don't think i see my dad cry
either yeah just gaslight the [ __ ] out
of the family yeah
yeah i think maybe don't mask it joe he
didn't cry when he saw you cutting his
piano streaks
yamaha
i think maybe one maybe once i saw my
decorate maybe once maybe yeah damn what
was it when was it which i don't
remember i just remember seeing his eyes
you know and being like holy just well
it up yeah do you think um
so like
our generation is probably the beginning
of starting to talk about [ __ ] like this
and then like the younger ones are but
even in our generation right there's
still a lot of like you're being a [ __ ]
and all that stuff there's a ton of it
yeah probably that even happened until
maybe we were like in our 20s where we
started hearing stuff like that so even
like we spent half of our lives more
than half not talking yeah and not
knowing how to process it yeah and the
part and then only like a minority of
our lives we just started opening up a
little bit well because first you have
to even recognize that you're going
through some [ __ ] i remember i'd be
[ __ ] angry yelling at people wanting
to fight them and thinking i'm not that
angry
you know like you have to understand
that you're going through it first i
also remember in high school you know
like people would like [ __ ] obviously
high school is just wild right it's like
a bullying ground for stuff like that
and you're like sitting in class people
making fun of you
and i remember um
my one of my friends the same thing he
got made fun of he's about to shed a
tear but the natural thing to like
support him in that moment was that hey
dude don't let him see your tears you're
gonna [ __ ] kill you if they see that
that's true yeah you know what i'm
saying yeah yeah yeah and it's like
that's that's my way of being a friend
right and
now i think about that and i'm like you
should have cried with him bro you'd
have cried first maybe
maybe you know what i mean like how do
you respond in those situations how do
you like shake that mold isn't there
isn't that in uh
what was that uh adam sandler where he
puts piss on his pants so the other kid
doesn't get me yeah
is there still a line though where
some people are being a [ __ ] dude for
sure those lines are very blurry that's
like questions that need to be asked
because like even though even though
like yeah you know someone's feeling
suicidal should like [ __ ] address
that some people be feeling suicidal
over the most entitled [ __ ] sometimes
because they because their starbucks
order was wrong but almost nowadays too
it's like the phrase mental health and
like using the term anxiety
is like almost used to the point where
it's like
a catchphrase these days it's like
i think it's kind of a necessary thing
right so it's like it's one of those
things where we went we were so far the
other way we have to kind of start all
the way over here over correcting and
then kind of find a nice balance yeah
the thing that people say too would be
like like to your point
um you know like anytime everyone anyone
that lives in like a first world country
is like crying about some [ __ ] going oh
look at like look at that country like
you're so entitled but then i think the
thing that people say it's like well
that's my experience right so maybe them
getting their starbucks order all [ __ ]
up is like
reason to jump off a building or
whatever but i it's hard for me to
understand but don't we know that that's
not what it is by now you know what i'm
saying yeah like like my grandpa yelling
about how my grandma um made too much of
something and so nobody can eat all of
it for example it wasn't about that
right but we all go oh grandpa's being
stupid again but he's really masking
some other [ __ ] probably saw like 10
people die in europe and he's like
damn why am i alive yeah why why me yeah
he watched his whole his whole uh
platoon get shot up every single person
died except for him every single oh he
was the last man standing yeah the only
survivor yeah but that's the kind of
[ __ ] where you're like you know like
it's a it's about the thing that we're
all laughing at like a guy at mcdonald's
the other day blows somebody away
because his fries are cold do we really
think that that's why he did it like you
know i mean yeah i hate cold fries
that like like they go onto instagram to
vent for like 10 minutes right and then
the whole 10 minutes they're venting
about something that
at least on the surface seems very like
trivial
like how do we know
what it really is about do we take their
word for it or like i don't know man
to me it's just about trying to treat
people like people a little bit more and
a little bit less like they're just
being [ __ ]
riri's
you know what i mean
i've heard that so long yeah it's just
like you know because we'd love to just
write somebody off and just go like
we're [ __ ] addicted to it as a
culture we can't wait to just write
somebody off and go that's this person
there's like that and he's like i [ __ ]
you bye and we keep walking
there's also like self preservation
though right like um because because you
will see stuff like that or like people
will will pull out that energy where
they're having like the hardest day or
whatever not just your friends but just
like random people i literally ordered
some [ __ ] food that got delivered the
other day i go outside and uh the guy
put my my food down on the sidewalk and
he's in the middle of the street this is
that night he's taking photo the moon or
whatever right and then i came out he's
like oh wow you came out so quick uh i
was just sorry i was just taking a photo
of the moon it was nice and i was like
hey man enjoy yourself then he comes by
he's like no dude i can't you're
literally talking to the person who's
like the worst life in the world
and i'm like whoa i was i tripped out
for a second and i was like
all the more reason to enjoy yourself
man and then he's having his food he's
like no i just told you i can't
and then he goes
anyways and he hands me the food right
and so this what the [ __ ] i have no
relationship with this guy so also
there's also a part of me that like
almost uh i don't know subconsciously
there's like a self-preservation mode
that goes in where i'm like also like i
don't need toxic energy in my life too
you know what i'm saying for sure yeah
yeah yeah so like i feel like there's
you know if you get exposed to it a lot
too a part of you is kind of like what
i need to keep myself like also healthy
and in my way no for sure yeah i also
think like
that's just weird social skills because
there's no rapport with you yeah it's
like it's like a cashier yeah ralph's is
like how's your day going and you go i
almost killed myself you son of a [ __ ]
you know like it's like
that's like
i mean that's not normal social skills
it's wild and it's fun to like go look
at it and just laugh at that because
that's where my brain usually goes right
but then it's it is really interesting
to think about what's behind it like i i
i sure yeah like they're at a breaking
point that's why they're they're not
being you know
you know like like something that i'm
trying or whatever to do more because i
definitely did the first thing more
in the past what do you mean just write
people off well i'll just laugh at
something and because it's funny and and
then move on i do think that um when
someone is close though like that when
there is the rapport when when we have
years together
um to me if they're acting out of
character
then it's like oh something's really up
but they can't say it or maybe they
don't recognize it and then i'm just
like
i'll dig
but if if i don't see that then it's
hard to dig you know what i mean like if
people are masking and they're really
good at it yeah then it's hard to even
know to reach out of course so then if
if if patty is telling people to just
like open up a little bit and if someone
does open up and they never did before
that's when i'm like
what's going on that's huge but if
they're complaining every [ __ ] day
yeah then it's like shut the [ __ ] up
you're over extending your [ __ ]
venting can you mask some more yeah
a little bit more or just try to deal
with it first yeah
so it's always easier to talk about like
an issue before it explodes as an issue
right like yeah if something was like
bothering you
even though it's like kind of trivial
it's actually easier to talk to somebody
about a trivial problem to get over
versus like you're like oh it's trivial
i don't want to talk about it then like
[ __ ] three months later it's not
trivial anymore it's [ __ ] you up you
know what i mean and then there's it's
harder to dig out of that hole it's
harder for your friends to understand
where you're coming from because they're
like i had no idea how do you you know
what i mean so it's like there is there
is that line where it's like am i being
a [ __ ] but at the same time if you can
kind of like nip something in the bud
and you know you can get through it or
you you have the support system get
through it faster so you can move on you
know i mean otherwise things can build
up with with lack of communication or
lack of just that channel there's also
weirdness with when you when you think
of the idea of like somebody asking for
help
in your mind the optimal
tone is very eloquent but most people
everyone's different so they all have a
different way of expressing like yo help
me out especially when it's wrong some
people honestly sound [ __ ] annoying
some people sound really like like
people attack you exactly yeah they have
like different ways of doing it it's
never the way that like like when
patty's saying it like our instinct is
to imagine a friend that we already
trust saying like yo like just bringing
it out but most of the timing and come
out like that it's not well packaged
that's kind of like a lot of the time
that's like you know why you're [ __ ]
up it was like what the [ __ ] and then
you dig deeper and you're like oh it had
nothing to do with me but they attacked
me to mask their own pain like some
people probably already know somebody
like that and they're like in their mind
they're like oh if anybody ever came to
me i would help them but yo you probably
already know somebody that's been
expressing it but you don't recognize it
because it's not
it's not in the way you is the hardest
thing to actually get to the words like
hey i need help exactly yeah that's so
[ __ ] difficult you know it's even
admit it let alone say it and manifest
because you also end up like getting
insecure about the idea of like man if i
say this then i really do have a problem
yeah i'm vulnerable now you know what
i'm saying so like it's a whole [ __ ]
slippery slope of that stuff but that's
why getting it getting at it early
recognizing that you can be vulnerable
that's why honestly anytime somebody's
like hey how are you doing like i'll
just say it i might not be sad about it
but if shit's hitting the fan things are
good i'll be like oh shit's like kind of
bad right now but it's not like yo whoa
was me it's more like i need to be
honest yeah before this turns into
something else versus the small talk
like oh shit's cool it's time when it's
not you know what i mean right it takes
so much self-awareness though because i
remember being in that state of mind and
getting so used to deflecting so that
that became my autopilot to the point
where you're you're in you don't even
recognize that you need help because
that becomes a part of your personality
where you're really good at bearing
everything that's painful yeah and then
so like if you're like these guys
who's in the macho world um then
everything's a [ __ ] joke and or
everything is just that doesn't happen
to me i don't get depressed none of that
stuff those are weak people not me so
then even if you do need the help i
think it's hard to even talk about it
and say hey i need i have a problem
because if the problem doesn't exist in
your head then why would you reach out
for help so i think it's like a group
effort of like people being like man is
that guy all right
maybe we need to talk to him well
there's hella branding out there too
it's like it's like hey you're a toxic
man and so it's like you know there's
like all this [ __ ] out there that's like
man i'm just being i'm just trying to be
like myself and then oh i'm branded as
this person now and so now if i'm
supposed to say something
i'm being a toxic man or something like
there's just confusion out there about
terms and like it's like oh [ __ ] i'm a
nazi apologist what the [ __ ] did i do
there's also um
adding to that is like i remember
um being told like oh you could tell me
anything whatever and then i open up and
i get punished for opening up and not
communicating in the way that they want
to hear
and it becomes about them that are hurt
that are hurt or whatever and i'm just
like dude we'll [ __ ] it then i'm not
going to open up yeah yeah it also
doesn't help when i mean like even on
like fresh and fit podcasts they talk
about like any man who's opening up like
that women do not want to [ __ ] date
you
it's like
yeah it's like maybe some women don't
like
dude
it's hard too when like yeah if you're
on the first date and you're [ __ ]
crying yeah yeah yeah red flag for sure
unless the first date was titanic too
then we can understand that
[Music]
do